yeah have you guys ever been recognized
in your home country have we talked
about this on trash taste before i don't
know well i i feel like it's going to be
even more insane now
tell me what you've been recognized in
the uk i mean
i've been recognized once i feel i think
in an argus in brighton oh gosh yeah
[ __ ]
um oh god it's a terrible storm so it's
the whole gimmick of this the whole
gimmick of this store is that you don't
actually like get to look at the
products it's a warehouse but you get to
look at the massive like 10 page no 10
page 400 page book and you're going oh
is this the place where you were talking
about like your christmas gifts or
whatever yeah yeah yeah basically just
imagine amazon
you have to go there and you don't have
a computer screen to browse everything
you just have a massive book
notes how they're still in business yeah
yeah
that seems sounds very outdated it's
kind of like it's kind of like the
blockbuster recognizing
yeah it's really weird just one of the
cashiers recognized me it's not a very
exciting story
have you ever gotten that before where
like someone working at an establishment
recognizes you and you got like a thing
out of it no but if they do i'm very
open
it's but like i've i've heard stories
about uh now about some of well cindy
just went back to america and apparently
she was just in a bar
and uh she got recognized
and uh
that's not good that's not good it's
sydney's content yeah yeah
yeah well she was she got recognized
because uh she was obviously my fiance
and she was just
and all the guys said was just uh oh
yeah are you sydney and she's like yeah
oh where's gone
she's like oh he didn't come here and i
was like oh say he had to go on for me
[Applause]
don't do that
don't do that don't do that would be
like say hi to joey and garfield yeah
yeah
and what what am i going to say yeah
by the way random dude i just met says
hi it's like what do we say to that look
it's like we appreciate you guys coming
up to us and saying hi that's cool and
all but like don't don't like make us be
the messenger for another person that's
right no one
you know the 800th century i'm not a
messenger i'm not like here to convey
messages for you right i got recognized
one time at um midnight on a bus which
was terrifying oh god i was going to the
gym um
and yeah the the bus went right outside
my house to the gym right it was perfect
it was 24 hours as well so it's good
and i was on my way back from the gym i
was extremely sweaty and there's only
two people on this bus me and him and he
was right at the back wearing a hoodie
in the back just like
oh [ __ ] and i was like what the [ __ ] so
then i'm i'm i'm sitting close to the
front on the second level yeah and i'm
just listening to music and i'm like
yeah
and then i feel like a
on my back
that's scary and i'm like
i'm like what what he's like
hey man you see dog
and i was like yeah yeah i'm serious
what's up and he's like i love your
videos and i'm like thanks man and she
walked off
so like i was like
that's so scary
i was like what he was like still hoodie
and everything on when he came up yeah
it's like you see dog just brick [ __ ]
else yeah he was massive and i was like
oh thanks man nice i was like this is my
house
i got i got recognized uh in in
akihabara you see i recognize a lot
obviously yeah every time i should go
with you there it was like i always i
feel that's where my people are i feel
like akihabara is like a cheat code
right because that's like saying you
gotta recognize that an anime convention
yeah because also akihabara surprisingly
has like the most uh like foreigners
yeah it does and obviously i mean it's
it's one of the most like you know
sensationalized like wacky lookout
places right in tokyo but uh i was
recognizing i get recognized for pretty
much every time i go to akyobra but the
one time i uh went to you know i was
like running a little running a little
short on my on my hentai might uh might
pop into a melon books which is a store
where you can buy a hentai and uh
and uh you know peruse the the goods oh
[ __ ] are you the anime man yeah and as i
was perusing through some stuff i i
gotta tap on the shoulder and it's like
are you joey i'm like i thought she'd be
like the lolly section
the wrong place man and he's like yeah
what i'm like yeah i am high and i was
like oh no like of all like and i was
like holding a dog and i was about to
buy as well i'm like worst timing and
and you know he had like a bag as well
so he obviously just like finished at
the cash register and the guy was like
what are you doing here i'm like what
the [ __ ] do you think i'm doing here
i jack off like really like really are
you are you sure you're a fan of me
because if you are you would know
exactly what i am doing here i am
holding the thing i am about to buy you
can see that so i'm like so all i said
was just
just buying some hentai
and it was like oh sick dude
all right bye
we just walked out it's just like what
kind of interaction can you have in that
place because i
i have exactly the same experience the
place i can't recognize the most is that
yeah it's those melon books all right it
starts all right i've been recognized
like three times in a melon books and
i'm like why why is it just like a
doujin store yeah yeah it's just like a
complete dozing store yeah basically
when sydney is just like running out of
ideas for content she just goes there
yeah and she's like oh just this and
then she's like is gone with you
yeah melon books
are like the two like big big hentai
stores now bro i always get recognized
and i haven't been recognized often but
when i do it's always when i look like
[ __ ] it's never it's never when i've
made an effort to look good it's never
in the jojo suit you know it's never
when i've got my drip game on yeah
you know i remember
one time i went to like there was a
sainsbury's name which is a normal
supermarket yeah yeah and i was wearing
sweatpants flip-flops you know the [ __ ]
which i actually don't even normally do
that i would normally even i would
normally put the effort into wear jeans
yeah yeah actually no i lie no just back
when i thought that wearing jeans was a
luxury
if i was working why why is it a luxury
uh it doesn't work so i okay actually
i'm going let's go on a detour because
it was a [ __ ] story anyway i basically
got recognized as sweatpants it's not
funny different
is this why you uh refuse to wear wash
jeans because it's
luxury no no no no sir that's not shitty
that's that's not a
so i had this thing for a very long time
well this isn't this isn't a meeting
this is a general thing i used to just
only wear like sweatpants when i was at
home if i wasn't leaving the house i
wouldn't wear jeans i would just wear
sweatpants i still do that but now
i changed my mind and now i only wear
jeans in the house what
how do you how do you bring yourself to
do that i do that what because
what happened was that i started just
feeling like [ __ ] i'm just like not
working right so i was like maybe maybe
if i like dress like i'm not a slob i
might work a little better oh you you
laugh but it's it's it's a real [ __ ]
thing it actually works like i i i wear
jeans not because i want to but because
it's the only way i'm going to look but
when you wear in when you're wearing a
pair of jeans nicely they feel like
better than anything i i feel like my
day hasn't started until i put all my
put on my jeans sometimes i try to work
like an american fighting for freedom
i just hadn't started my day until i put
on my denim jeans
honestly like so sometimes i try to work
and i'm in like sweatpants or sometimes
just in my [ __ ] boxes because like
i sleep in my boxes and i just don't get
anything done right as soon as i put on
my jeans the day is started
i am ready to work because i don't know
man i i just wake up and go time to work
and then i just don't think you've if
you go mine doesn't matter man yeah but
if you go to jeans you just work harder
yeah just just give you a look
you know and like one time i even went
so far as to start wearing like nice
shirts like like like a suit shirt but
yeah but suit shirts when i was making
videos because i was like i was
convinced that this is the next step to
increasing my productivity
yeah it didn't work and i just hated it
yeah right but i i i i found the happy
medium but jeans and a shirt i felt like
if i can dress enough like a t-shirt or
like a college shirt not like this oh
yeah yeah but like i i think the
sweatpants were the the big
big player because i basically got to
the mindset of i want to wear outfits
that i could just go out to any social
gathering or
i can wear this to anywhere you know
right and so i felt like it helped my
productivity so if you work at home a
lot and you've you've gotten to have
sweat pantsing all the time
you know maybe just try wearing what you
would wear to work but what what okay
well what would you do during the summer
then i should still work just like full
on jeans
ac blasting
i mean i i wear whatever i i would wear
to the trash taste office that's
basically like my dress code at home but
like i would never wear anything too
comfy i guess because if i feel if
comfort is the enemy of productivity
well because if i'm being sweatpants i
just like i feel like i should be in my
bedroom yeah i get that watching tv